I'll be throw okay my legs
suck oh no no no no whoa what what is oh
my god is that me is bread oh boy
oh come on now what are you going store
for me okay okay okay okay all right
oh I'm safe okay good well I'm probably
still gonna die okay there's my lovely
no come on get in in the winner's circle
run run run run one here before the cops
come
mara are impossible you have to
sacrifice oh I have to sacrifice
I'm not alive take a few narrows up my
nose
I did it did I did it where's the wind
it was right there i won technically
spike good luck markiplier you're gonna
need it whoa yeah I wanted Marga blasts
war throw food dad I'm like a ninja I'm
so quick right into your crotch
well I don't think I'll be a bother
have a unique strategy that I just
learned to sell these kids okay I don't
think my son is alive anymore but I
don't think that matter cuz I goddamn it
we'll get
even I have forgotten the level okay I'm
dead story I tell you I once at a little
Boy Scout come over and I took him to
Africa or something like that and then
he's dead now watch out for those blades
which is if you die anyway your help
smuggler jet fall one day my spa my
spines are correct market last bike fall
will not be beaten in no margul are tim
wall hi okay hi thanks Tim oh okay then
that's blue ball Betty I'm imagining but
blue ball Betty turned blue ball
horrible I'll show you what's impossible
lies and slander
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye